yeah yeah my apartment just arrived I
told you back ok bye hi welcome to the
European Parliament and Sarah excited
for your birthday
I have Jenny Reece case with me ok I'll
save it for you follow me
[Music]
what a busy day today yes it's the same
Akane yes this is our new trainee it's
their first day well good luck
thank you well I'll leave you here I'm
coming back in two seconds okay what's
out are you okay yes yes I'm all right
sorry I was distracted
I just thank you thank you very much I'm
really sorry
thank you thank you I really have to go
president is waiting for me now okay
come on let's go see your new colleagues
okay
[Music]
isn't that the president birthdays no
it's mine what
oh no the briefcases must have been
switched up let's get out wait according
to his schedule the president is in the
box box the plenary session starts in a
few minutes we need to find the
president's assistant before it starts
[Music]
[Music]
wait
I'm so happy you found me I was looking
for it everywhere thank you
I think we mix that our briefcases thank
you I really have to go
the president is waiting for his gavel
to study speech I think we are just in
time the plenary session is about to
start
good job that was a special way to start
your first day at the U P let's have a
look inside of the
[Applause]